well thousands of children are in the
foster care system here in Clark County
but the need for foster parents it's
really never ending the county put out
several pleas recently for people to
register Victoria saw joins us live in
studio with the impact you can make in a
child's life
a child has no control over their home
life so when they're taken away the
county says one of the places they're
often staying in are hospitals until
they find a home and you could have what
it takes to give that to them
11 month old Jordan now has a home and a
parent to call Mom that is when she does
learn how to talk
basically my job was just to love on her
to do all the day in the day out kind of
stuff Nicole Farley brought baby Jordan
home at five weeks old as a foster
Farley had already fostered and adopted
Cali and Reina both under five when
Jordan came into the picture I had
absolutely no idea that I was going to
adopt one let alone three you know you
fall in love with the kids Farley
started fostering a few years ago not
knowing what she was getting herself
into but knew she needed to once you're
kind of in the system on this side of it
and you see what the need is it's really
hard to step away knowing that there are
so many kids that need help but instead
of stepping into Parenthood Farley
wheeled herself in Farley is
wheelchair-bound but that's not stopping
her from Mom duties but it's groups like
Foster change that work with Clark
County to train and support foster
parents like Farley there's really
nothing that discriminates you from
providing care a lot of the training is
getting to know more about yourself and
far Lee has gotten to know herself
better than she thought she did that I
have the capacity to love more than I
thought that I did
oh you have love to give then that's
really what they need
right now Clark County says they have
just over 680 foster homes for children
and teens but they would like to have at
least a thousand at any given time
Kirsten Victoria there are three
thousand children in the foster care
system so as she's been reporting if
you'd like to sign up to open your heart
in your home we have information on our
website at 8newsnow.com and parents will
go through a nine week training period
you